you're pulling a power move right now
and i'll tell you why i'll tell you
you're pulling a power move
most women so i'm 40 again 41. um and i
so there's friends of mine that are
might might still
they're not still married and even
there's girls that are a little older
than victoria they're on the wrong side
of 30 i'll say right what's the wrong
side what what's that the older one
they're older than third you know the
the only joke but here's the ugly
terminology it happens they're on
they're on the you can fix it if you
work they're on the other side of 30.
okay
um
but they're very concerned
with getting married
having kids
and they're you know like like the
famous scene marissa told me my because
my [ __ ] biological clock is ticking
we all know this you have basically
pulled a power move like he kind of
compared you to the alpha in the
relationship you're like look i don't
even want kids
so there's no clock that's ticking that
i gotta waste my time i don't even give
a [ __ ] if i get married i'm good i have
the money
like everything you're controlling
you're controlling your nerve 100 but
there's very few women that want that in
my opinion meaning they're not looking
to get married they don't need no man to
support i don't need no man that kind of
a thing i'm not i'm a liar you're the
outlier malcolm gladwell will call you
an outlier so you're basically pulling a
power move whereas the the move
typically
what i've seen
is that women are like kind of like
they're freaking out that you know they
want to give me they want to have kids
so what do they do as they get older
i don't know how long that will last a
month but eventually
they will settle they'll say you know
what
you know i was kind of the hot girl when
i was 22 and maybe i was like the hot
girl when i was 26 but now i'm like you
know 34 30 whatever and like
you're worse off like that how do you
not know that this is what girls do am i
wrong on this
no you're not wrong because
i definitely have these like minds
go ahead victoria like i'm aware of the
way that he thinks like those thoughts
cross my mind and then
yeah like i could choose like you but i
think your choice really is you
controlling everything whereas like i'm
choosing to
focus on my feminine energy and like um
try to
allow myself to open up to the right
partner because of what i want as an end
goal that's so cool and
something hey grace talk though no
that's fantastic because it's actually
something that i was going to say when
because it's something that you said
about i've become the man i want to date
i did do that
and that's like again we're talking in
this but that's just not me anymore and
so for that reason embracing feminine it
is so much more difficult so i used to
go after i used to date i used to do so
much right so like that's that's why now
i'm like i it's okay if it comes that's
wonderful so you're what you're talking
about right now is is a common complaint
that i get from like women that i i
counsel uh and as young as say 28 or 29
as old as 40 and they say the same thing
i can't find a guy who is my you know
socioeconomic equal i can't find and of
course that means above me but uh i i
can't find the right guy where you know
and it ends up being the sort of litmus
test for guys because they're not
measuring up to what i want him to be so
that i can have a relationship going on
into the future whether or not that's
what you want to do is different but so
the women that are coming to me are
saying i did everything by the book i
got my degree i got my career i have my
business i'm i'm making six figures i've
got the you know the apartment in miami
whatever it is i got the little dog and
it's like and i can't find any guy who's
ready to go forward with me into the
rest of my life right now and the reason
for that is because you made yourself
into the man that you want to you want
to go forward with in in life and the
guys that are going to measure up as we
were saying a minute ago with the the
apex uh you know example of that guy
those men don't want to get with you
they want to get with a woman who is
feminine women they want to get with a
woman who is in touch with their female
sight so what do they say well how do i
do that how do i get in touch with my
feminine side because if i say you need
to become you need to develop your
feminine side you need to embrace your
femininity a little bit more because
you've been taught over the course of a
lifetime to be the alpha the alpha
female
then you have to dumb yourself down you
have to dumb yourself down
no i'm not saying you do but they feel
like they say so i have to dumb myself
down i've been told that they think that
embracing femininity means dumbing
themselves down
no i'm just kidding this is the best
but you've been told we'll come to
victoria but you've been told to dumb
yourself down you're saying yes by who
why everybody
don't oh god don't you do that girl i
couldn't you keep that phd up there but
what does that mean who who has
literally said rebecca look kind of dumb
it down a little bit several men they
say it is intimidating to other men
is what
that's being yourself
see when you couch it in terms of like
threatening or intimidating or whatever
it's not so much like guys who aren't
going to be with you they're just
they're the guys that you want to get
with they're not intimidated they just
don't have anything to do with you
they're not dating situations i'm
talking about other situations you're
saying
you're
i'm not really sure what kind of
construct you've created and then you're
talking
to me as if i belong and what you're
doing so i think we kind of lost each
other a little bit like what you're
saying this
her as is
basically and i'm not i'm not whatever
but i don't know what ideally yeah i
deal in statistics
hard numbers and this is why i just deal
with people well this is kind of what
we're saying that there uh this is what
shout out to fresh and fair he said
something that there's the probable and
the possible something like that right
what was that what was that yeah the the
probability or the possibility of you
finding the the perfect guy is certainly
out there but the probability goes down
depending on the choices that you've
made and the results of your life that
that are ensuing because of that
i i i feel that because like i'll never
have a high school sweetheart like
certain things in my life
decrease the chances of like finding a
certain person like my college
sweetheart was
an [ __ ] cheater
then i met the lovely soznick
just kidding
but like i wasn't meeting great guys no
no
but
so yeah like statistically i'm like
i haven't i'm like in a different box
now because of my life choices
i just find this but i will say that i
will say that you have age like find one
like you're a lot i hope take this the
right way a lot more
um more polished and like just you like
you have your [ __ ] together versus when
i met you and like in the party phase
yeah so kudos to you
you